en france plus de 125 mille femmes
jouent au foot en club amateur soit
seulement 7,6 pour cent du nombre total
de licenciés pourtant l'intérêt des
françaises pour le ballon rond ne date
pas d'hier
j'aime taper dans un ballon j'aime
courir après le ballon j'aime bien le
sport d'équipé puis football par dessus
tout mais la pratique de ce sport n'est
pas facilitée pour les filles
déjà il a fallu l'attendre 1970 pour que
le foot féminin soit reconnue par la
fédération française et depuis longtemps
elles doivent faire face à de nombreux
préjugés
est-ce que vous pensez que le football
est compatible avec l'évanouissement
notre féminité
bien sûr en 1970 celui lui sont jouées
sont inscrites en club porté par
l'effervescence des coupes du monde
masculine 74 et 78
ce chiffre passe à près de 12000 huit
ans plus tard soit près de sept fois
plus en 1974 cet entraîneur défendent
est la pratique du foot pour les filles
ce n'est pas un sport qui est opposé à
la morphologie féminine
à la féminité c'est un sport à mon avis
qui est un sport d'adressé qui est un
sport de l'habileté de souplesse
l'intuition et ses qualités à sont avant
tout des qualités féminines l'intuition
la souplesse l'adresse l'intelligence
dans le jeu les intérêts des françaises
pour le football continue de
s'intensifier en 21 ans le nombre de
licenciés augmente encore
considérablement pour atteindre près de
35000 en 1999 encore une fois une coupe
du monde celle de 98 en france a
contribué à cette envolée
un succès parfois difficile à suivre
pour certains clubs qui a une demande
qui actuellement n'est pas suivi par un
manque de structures au niveau des clubs
féminins et qui ne sont pas assez
représentée au niveau des différentes
régions aujourd'hui sur près de 15000
club de foot amateur français seuls
quatre cent quatre-vingt dix-huit sont
labellisés écoles féminine de football
pourtant le nombre des licenciés ne
cesse de grimper depuis les années 90 en
2013 cette spécialiste du foot féminin
évoqué une autre priorité pour sa région
c'est d'apporter au moins une femme dans
l'encadrement et d'avoir quelqu'un qui
m'avait qui materne un petit peu c'est
toujours aussi bien et notamment pour
les vestiaires c'est très important pour
la fédération française de football le
développement du foot féminin est
aujourd'hui une priorité
elle espère passer le cap des 200 mille
licenciés d'ici à 2020
la coupe du monde féminine 2019 créera
certainement des vocations
[Musique]